>>Female Presenter: Hello everyone.
Thank you so much for coming to this Tech
Talk on "The Delancey Underground."
In case any of you guys are lost, no, this
is not free food for Eleven Madison Park.
My name is Julia Ramsey, otherwise known as
the girl who is spamming your inboxes this
morning.
And this is James Ramsey.
He's an architect and owns RAAD Studio, an
architecture firm on the Lower East Side.
>>James Ramsey: By the way, we're related.
>>Female Presenter: If anyone was wondering.
And this is Dan Barasch.
He's actually a former Googler and is currently
the Vice President of PopTech.
>>Dan Barasch: Yes.
>>Female Presenter: With no further ado--.
>>Dan Barasch: Yeah.
So, I mean, first of all, thanks so much for
having us and thanks, Julia, for--.
I heard you were posting flyers all night.
So, we're super appreciative for that.
And thanks for some friends in the audience.
It's good to see you guys.
I guess we're really excited about sharing
this with you.
So, I guess we'll just kind of kick it off.
>>James Ramsey: OK.
We'll look at some pictures and speak generally
about the idea we're proposing here.
But in a nutshell, and if you've seen, maybe
come across this in the media, it's oftentimes
been called the Low Line for some fairly obvious
reasons which you'll probably see in a second.
But at the heart of it is a concept that we're
working on to build an underground park underneath
the Lower East Side in an abandoned trolley
terminal.
And it uses it innovative solar technology
to actually accomplish this.
And we'd like to do is just walk through the
genesis of the idea, talk a little bit about
how it works, talk about some of the design
issues, talk about the technology, too.
And then, generally speak about the process
and maybe even have a very light Q and A,
where you guys can just talk to us about it.
All right.
So, let's start here.
Does anyone here know who this guy is?
>>Dan Barasch: Oh, come on.
>>MALE #1: Shigeru Miyamoto.
>>James Ramsey: You're awesome.
Shigeru Miyamoto, for those of you who do
not recognize this man, is an amazing fellow.
He is the guy that invented Super Mario Brothers.
And I'll explain why this is significant in
a second, but a couple years ago, the New
Yorker wrote an article about Shigeru Miyamoto
and why it was that he designed such amazing
video games.
And if you think about it, Super Mario Brothers
is really simple, right?
It's just a 2-D world and you're a plumber
running around jumping on mushrooms and turtles.
But it's laid out in such a way that what
seems like a very simple map that you're running
around in actually has all these levels and
layers of complexity.
It has all these secrets for you to discover.
Like for example, in this screen right here
I think, somewhere over on the left side of
the screen, you can jump up, you hit a secret
brick and a beanstalk pops out or something
like that.
But anyway, throughout this game and also
another famous game that he created called
"Legend of Zelda," they're sort of peppered
with all these tiny little details that make
exploring it something that never quite feels
finished and gives it a level of complexity
that make these things endlessly interesting
and something you want to play again and again
and again.
Quite literally in this picture, you can jump,
obviously, in the pipe over here.
And you go down into this secret underworld.
So, the reason I'm talking about this is that
well, for one thing, this is New York, by
the way.
New York City is an amazing, amazing town.
And I think that there is a similarity of
level of complexity in New York and also a
lot of other cities of course.
But this is the city I know best and the city
I love the most.
And every once in a while, New York City will,
like Super Mario Brothers, just peel back
a layer of the onion and just give you a tiny
little glimpse into how amazingly complex
it actually is and how many secrets it's still
hiding from you.
And that's one of the most compelling things,
to me anyway, about urbanism in New York.
It makes me wanna live here.
It makes me endlessly fascinated with the
city.
And I think it's an extremely powerful quality.
Now, I think recently we've had this age in
which they've knocked down a lot of stuff--and
no offense if this is your apartment building
or the Starbuck's that you really enjoy frequenting--I'm
just using it as an example.
But recently, they've knocked down a lot of
stuff.
They've taken away a lot of our historical
legacy--all these little, quirky things.
And actually, now that I think of it, you
guys have enabled Maps functions and Search
functions that have really taken away a lot
of surprises out of the world and a lot of
the mystery out of our cities.
I'm not saying that's a bad thing.
It's just a reality.
However, you can have this landscape still
co-exist with some of these secrets I'm referring
to.
For example, just down the street from my
apartment.
I live on Renwick Street, which by the way
in and of itself, is kind of a secret.
No one knows where Renwick Street is.
But it's over near the Holland Tunnel.
And if you are walking down the sidewalk and
staring at your feet, which one day I was,
you will notice that there's this little sign
there.
And I'm not gonna read it, but effectively
it says, hear ye, hear ye, here was ye olde
waterfront of New York City.
And this is where the sailboats and all these
masted ships used to pull up.
And actually embedded in the sidewalk right
there, are these wooden piles just right there
in the sidewalk.
And you would never really notice this unless
you happened to have glanced at it or if you
happened to know it was there.
But I guess the point of all this is that
it's still there.
And you have to know where to look.
But New York will still find a way to surprise
you with its hidden complexities.
And New York is not so much like other East
Coast older cities, like Boston or Philadelphia
for example, where they're really wearing
their history on their sleeve.
You actually have to seek it out a little
but in New York because we are so market-driven
and forward-looking.
But every once in a while, again, there's
certain places if you know where to look.
And this is quite literally one of them.
I don't know if anyone had the good fortune
to have done this.
But this is Atlantic Avenue in front of Trader
Joe's in downtown Brooklyn.
And underneath, inside one manhole cover,
you can go down it and that's what's in there.
So, this is actually down there.
It was a secret abandoned railroad tunnel
built in the 1840s.
And some guy--just some random guy--it was
this self-trained history buff, right?
Went down a manhole cover one day in the late-80s.
I think it was the day after Indiana Jones
and the Temple of Doom came out.
And he went down in here and he was like,
"Oh, my God.
Look what I found."
And lo and behold, there it is.
It's huge.
It goes all the way from Trader Joe's all
the way to the water.
But I guess this is to illustrate a point
that it's down there.
And in general, we have this vast underworld
lurking underneath the service of New York.
I mean, other cities of course as well, especially
European cities.
But we have this vast underworld lurking down
there.
We have something like, and I don't think
it's all cataloged, but we have something
like 13 acres of unused underground space
underneath New York.
That's a lot in New York, by the way.
So, here is maybe a less impressive one that's
over on, I think, Worth Street or something
like that.
And of course, this is the beautiful City
Hall Station.
If anyone has snoozed on the 6 train or been
reading a book and forgot to get off at the
last stop, at the Brooklyn Bridge stop, the
train will then circle around and loop around
to go back uptown.
And if you wake up for just that instant in
a panic from being stuck on the train, this
is probably what you'll see.
So, I'm not sure whether you're allowed to
be doing that, but if you have the chance,
it's pretty cool.
And I guess more specifically, this is the
space that we're looking at today.
Actually, I'll hand the clicker over to Dan,
but this is the Williamsburg Trolley Terminal,
built in 1903 and abandoned in 1948.
>>Dan Barasch: Yeah.
And James and in his work as an architect
and designer came across this site by befriending
a former MTA engineer, who got him interested
in this particular location, which is just
a couple blocks away from his office on the
Lower East Side.
And James and I, just by way of introduction,
started talking about this particular project
because of my personal love and interest of
the subway and the city in general, but also
I was separately thinking about an idea of
how we would potentially bring art into the
underground subway.
James had an entirely different angle, which
we'll get to actually, and is at the heart
of the actual project.
But this actual location, as you can see here,
there's a couple of fun details in this picture.
If you look--I think it's blown up enough--you
can see all the way in the back there some
people in topcoats and they sort of look old-timey.
>>James Ramsey: They're probably mustachioed
as well.
>>Dan Barasch: Mustachioed.
So, this is from the 1930s.
And essentially what you're looking at is,
this is the trolley turnaround back in the
days when the city used street cars primarily
to get around the city before the subways
were really the main way that people got around
the city.
And so, the trolleys would come over the Williamsburg
Bridge--and for those of you who are familiar
with this part of town, they would go underground
and this is essentially the terminal where
the cars would be stored, turn around, go
back over the bridge.
This is what it looks like today, actually.
We're able to hoodwink the MTA into a tour,
which is a lot harder than it sounds, and
when we got down there, we were really blown
away by the height, the scale of what you
can see down there.
Just again, sort of a sense of scale, you
can see that figure way, way, way in the back
in the center.
That's actually an MTA employee.
So, it's just this incredibly massive space.
It was wet 'cause there had just been a snowstorm.
And so there's a lot of runoff.
These are some more pictures of the location.
It's actually directly adjacent to the JMZ
line, if you guys take the JMZ and when you're
facing it to Brooklyn, you can actually see--.
We had a photo.
It's not there.
>>James Ramsey: It's the one after that.
>>Dan Barasch: The one after?
I'll show you in a sec.
So, if you're actually on the JMZ track, you
can actually look into the location.
And usually it's not lit, so it's this dark
expanse, but when it's lit you can see into
the location.
One of the incredible things that--.
This is a photo that we actually took during
our tour.
There's remnant cobblestone, remnant rail
lines, and it is the kind of that you get
down there--and James just talked about it--it's
like an Indiana Jones moment.
It's this incredibly exciting discovery almost
of this abandoned space.
>>James Ramsey: I also felt like it was the
scene in Lord of the Rings where they go into
the dwarf mine.
I don't know if anyone saw it.
Very similar.
>>Dan Barasch: That's kind of what it was
like.
So, this is the location for those of you
who may or may not be familiar with the neighborhood.
One the left there--.
This is actually Google Maps.
So, it's pretty awesome.
The yellow over there is the Williamsburg
Bridge.
And this is where Delancey Street ends and
when the Brooklyn Bridge starts.
So, it's directly below.
That's Delancey Street and it's that weird,
little hook there.
If you guys are familiar with Delancey Street
and you ever wondered why there's all that
weird, wasted space to the right when you're
facing the bridge, it's actually because of
the existence of this underground space that
most people don't know about.
Here's an old drawing from probably the turn
of the century of what the bridge may have
looked like back in its earlier days.
As I mentioned, the Williamsburg Bridge was
built in 1903 and obviously the trolley terminal
was built at the same time.
These are some other fun pictures of Delancey
Street in the 1930s.
And this is, you can see a lot of the elevated
track lines and a bustling streetscape.
But I think what's compelling about this is
you can see that it had a vibrant night life--,
streetscape, and it also has, as the Lower
East Side has always been, this crossroads
from a transportation perspective, but also
just culturally and from a merchant perspective
as well.
Which I think brings us to the current day
and again, this is a view from the Williamsburg
Bridge.
And you can see, actually, that there's a
really limited amount of green space in the
area.
You can see also that it's a space that is
friendly to cars, but is actually pretty challenging
for cyclists and for pedestrians.
It's one of the most dangerous parts of the
city from a cyclist and pedestrian perspective.
There was just a little girl who was actually
killed, unfortunately, walking across the
street just a couple weeks ago.
And it remains this large transportation question,
but also this livability question for the
neighborhood--how to make this particular
neighborhood, this particular node of the
city greener and more livable.
So, one of the answers to why this is the
case is the actual history of New York City.
And I don't know if you guys have been to
exhibit at the Museum of the City of New York,
but there's a really fun exhibit on the grid
and its creation of blocks--very geometric
blocks that span across the entire city.
And what those do is they're very efficient
from a real estate perspective and are designed
really for optimal economic output, but they
aren't really conducive to green space and
don't really allow for some of the sweeping
green spaces in parks that you see in less
gridded cities like many of the European capitals.
This is one of the images that we actually
have some across in our research and our zeal
for this project in a book called "How the
Other Half Lives," which is a really incredible
book on the history of the Lower East Side,
specifically in some of its darkest and most
dangerous and uncertain times in the 19th
Century actually.
And here what you see is a somewhat disturbing
image of a bunch of kids in an obviously very
unclean street, playing or relaxing, basically
next to the carcass of a dead horse.
And this was one of many images that actually
helped build a movement for the creation of
parks and specifically the creation of playgrounds
and spaces where children play and recreate
in a safe and clean environment.
So, this obviously brings us to where we are
today.
And again, if you guys have ever been to Delancey
Street or Lower East Side, you're familiar
with the fact that the streetscape isn't really
very friendly.
It's really not very fun and it's actually
quite dangerous to spend quality time on Delancey
Street, particularly in this part of Delancey
Street.
So, this is again a lot of our motivation
on why this particular project has come to
where we are.
This is another slide that helps point out
this fact in slightly more statistical terms.
You have the region that's known as the Community
Board Three's jurisdiction.
I don't know if you guys follow local politics,
but this area that comprises the East Village,
Lower East Side, and Chinatown is one of the
least green parts of the city when measured
in acres of green space per thousand residents.
And it's one of the least green parts of New
York City.
And it's also important to note, and what
comes in surprise to New Yorkers, that New
York actually has less green space than many
other high-density cities.
So, this is led to a sense of how do we think
about reclaiming Delancey Street, looking
back to the past, but also looking forward
and thinking creatively about what could potentially
be done with and for the neighborhood, but
more broadly thinking about how to solve for
some of the larger questions of this particular
really inspiring site?
So--.
>>James Ramsey: So, I mean, as Dan is saying,
the Lower East Side itself is a historically
neglected neighborhood, at least by the powers
that be.
And it's one in which infrastructure and commerce
and market-driven concerns have really formed
its development.
And so, it's a neighborhood that is very low
on green space.
We happen to have discovered that there is
this ginormous trolley terminal just lurking
beneath the surface, right at the foot of
the Williamsburg Bridge.
So, in a lot of ways, this made a perfect
site for us to look at to actually turn into
a public amenity.
And that's the goal of what we're trying to
accomplish here.
Now, you saw the pictures that we were just
looking at before, like the one on the bottom
right here.
It would be on the one hand, of course we
wanted to share that sense of, that thrill
of discovery that urban archaeology that we
experienced, actually, figuring out that this
thing was down there.
At the same time, in terms of sharing that
experience, it would be a stretch to say that
most people would wanna go down into that
space.
I mean, I thought it was incredibly cool,
but that's just me.
I think that most people would have an aversion
to going down into a space like that.
And so, we started thinking about what are
some of the natural solutions to actually
making that an accessible space that you would
actually want to go down into and spend time
in.
And one of the easiest answers to that is
to introduce natural sunlight.
The simplest and easiest way to introduce
natural sunlight into that space would probably
be to just cut a bunch of holes in the ceiling.
But unfortunately, the ceiling is Delancey
Street.
So, that would be, probably, a bad idea, right?
So, we looked at this.
Well, actually, it just happened rather, that
I was working on a technology at the time
that we actually found out about this space.
And that technology is something that perhaps
we can look to to actually satisfy those needs
of the space to create an appealing environment
to be used as a public amenity.
So, what is this technology then?
Well, this is a very diagrammatic version
of what this tech could be.
But in a nutshell, at the top side above the
street, like at a lamp post level or something,
you actually use a system of optics to concentrate
sunlight down into a tiny, tiny footprint,
a tiny little pellet of super-concentrated
light.
You take that light, you funnel it through
a tube or a fiber optic cable for that matter.
And you lead it to where you need it to go.
And then, you distribute it in the inverse
of the way you gathered it.
So, in effect, what you've done having gone
through that process is you've created a skylight
where you couldn't otherwise normally have
a skylight.
It's very similar, functionally speaking,
it's a fairly straightforward idea.
Functionally speaking, it's very similar to
a periscope or even an endoscope--something
like that.
But it's really just an optical device that
allows us to do this, right?
So, that has some pretty obvious advantages
for this specific site in that you've distilled
the footprint of the sky and sunlight down
to a tiny little point and that's all you're
cutting in the street.
So, you can free up the street level for cars
and people and dogs or whatever, and actually
just run this thing down there and then redistribute
it and then spread it back out and actually
achieve an effect where what you're looking
up at down in the space is a simulacrum of
what you're looking at with the collectors
above.
So, that's all fine and well, conceptually,
but we felt like we needed to actually see
if this idea--this kooky idea--worked.
So, we gathered together a few friends and
we went through the process of actually engineering
a system like this, and designing it and actually
fabricating it, too, which was a very telling
process.
In the end--this was probably last summer--we
ended up in the fifth floor walk-up of a buddy
of mine, sweating in the middle of summertime
in Chinatown, screwing together this device.
But so, it's very homemade.
But at the same time, we realized that it
is something that is possible and it is doable
and it works.
It's actually a fairly old process.
I mean, hearkening back to ancient Egypt,
they would cut shafts through their ceilings
to reflect light down into the tombs and stuff.
The skylight is obviously a version.
There's an invention called the "solar tube,"
that also accomplishes something very similar.
So, really this is just a variation on a very
ancient theme.
All right?
So, we built one.
This is a terrible picture and I apologize.
But this was taken with my Blackberry in my
office.
But this is the device.
This is a small, hand-held prototype version
of the technology.
And what you're seeing here is there's a gathering
instrument on the top.
The entire glass cube disconnects into two
pieces, like a Transformer.
And you connect the two sides and there you
go.
You have the three components.
So, there's someone from my office just setting
it up on the sidewalk on the Lower East Side.
This picture was taken in front of Sammy's
Roumanian.
Has anyone ever been there?
Yeah.
So, yeah.
We're just setting up this incredibly strange
and scary high-tech device in front of Sammy's
Roumanian's garbage actually.
And we got quite a few strange looks from
the staff at Sammy's.
There's me setting up the gathering instrument.
And there's some kid walking away with an
eyebrow.
[laughter]
And here's us plugging it in.
And here is Dan, rudely shining it in my face.
And so, it was an exploratory process, but
one that we felt was extremely valuable from
a conceptual point of view--ie., it works.
And also a technical perspective 'cause we
got to explore some of the technical hurdles
to actually fabricating an item like this.
Proof of concept.
All right.
So, that brings us to the space itself, right?
So, I had someone from my office go down to
MTA Archives and again, what was the term
you used?
>>Dan Barasch: Hoodwinked.
>>James Ramsey: Hoodwinked, yes.
So, we hoodwinked our way into stealing the
original engineering drawings for the space.
And the drawing is from 1902, the year before.
And so, we rolled out these ancient blueprints,
sat down there old school style with the little
triangle scales, measured the thing, and built
a 3-D model of every nut and bolt in the entire
space basically.
And as per the specifications in their drawings.
We then built a 3-D model of our prototype
technology, but written large on a large scale
that would be specifically applicable to the
space.
And we began to put the pieces together to
see, design-wise, what emerged.
And as we messed with it, this is what we
came up with.
So, this is quite literally that technology
directly modeled into the space itself.
And it just so happens, as part of the technical
exploration, we realized that we are transmitting
the wavelengths of light that plants want
to drink up for photosynthesis.
So, why not grow trees and grass down there,
too?
[pause]
The wide shot right here.
All right.
So, anyway.
This is our concept.
And it has a range of implications.
And the first time these images popped out
of the computer, it kind of gave me goose
bumps.
And we started going around, talking to various
friends about this idea, about his concept
in general.
We started looking into the history of the
Lower East Side itself, some of the dynamics
going on in the community.
And a very clear picture started to emerge,
both what the design, generally speaking,
would be, but also pointing to the fact that
this would be an incredible amenity for the
community that it's actually located in.
And so, we, for the last two years, have set
about the process of trying to push this forward
and actually make something real out of it,
to actually make this thing exist.
Conceptually and technically, it's something
that's actually possible and something very
doable.
From another standpoint, we have to actually
push forward in other ways to actually make
it a political and fiscal reality.
And so, let's see--.
Here's an image of the skylight.
I was gonna hand the clicker to you, though.
Here we go.
>>Dan Barasch: Yeah.
So, just a couple quick fun things about this.
I mean, even in this image itself, I mean,
a lot of these images have spoken for themselves.
I know you guys may have read some articles
on this.
And as we share this with people in the community
and friends of ours, what's really funny is
that people have said, "Oh, it's kind of like
a low line."
And that's actually really fun.
And they meant it as a compliment.
Get it?
Right.
It's like, Lower East Side, Low Line.
And I think it's a really fun comparison.
What the High Line guys have done is unbelievably
incredible, super inspiring.
So, one of the first few things that we did
when we basically set out to try to make this
thing a reality was to go talk to High Line
guys, which I think Robert and Josh have come
here multiple times.
I don't know if you guys have heard them speak
or seen their book.
They have a new book that's kind of like a
textbook on how to build a new park.
So, we've read that.
And basically, a lot of the advice that has
come from them is to really work on how we
need to understand the complexity and the
multiple layers of business owners and community
leaders in the Lower East Side, and work directly
with them on initiating a dialogue.
Not presenting something and then expecting
everyone to accept it, but really just grow
support for the idea over time.
So, in that vein, we've done a lot of things
that actually have been a bit of a learning
curve for both of us as well, like attend
community board meetings and engage with stakeholders
at the city and the state level.
And really learn a lot more about who gets
to decide what happens to this space.
A key piece here is that the core reality
is that the MTA currently owns the location
and is looking to put the proposal, essentially
open it up for proposals at some point later
this year.
There's also the reality that it's immediately
below one of the largest redevelopment areas
in the entire city--definitely in Manhattan--at
the moment.
So, the Lower East Side is about to be positioned
for some pretty tremendous change.
And a lot of developers are vying for the
locations really adjacent to the entire location.
So, we've been working with various city agencies
to understand more about that process, understand
more about what we can do there.
So, I think just to, and I can answer more
nitty-gritty questions if anyone is interested
in the political realities of what we're doing
or lives in the Lower East Side.
If any of you live on the Lower East Side
or in the neighborhood, I'd love to talk to
you more about it.
But essentially, I think what we're doing
is we're really bringing the community into
this over the course of this year to build
up support for the concept.
So, one of the first things that we're doing
in just two weeks’ time, is to launch a
kick starter campaign, where we'll be directly
inviting and bringing the community into that.
One of the things that we're hoping to do
is to actually build a full-scale mock-up
of this actual technology in a large, sizable
location so people will be able to experience
the technology itself, with their own eyes.
>>James Ramsey: Right.
Not Sammy's.
>>Dan Barasch: Yeah.
And not in front Sammy's garbage.
But also just to be able to envision what
an indoor park would look and feel like using
actual sunlight indoors.
And to continue this larger conversation that
we're having with the community around what
they would use this kind of a space for.
There's a whole host of supporters in the
community and in business and at the government
levels.
And we're really just planning to use the
rest of this year to get more people excited
about what we're up to.
So, that's where we are at this point.
And I'm sure there's probably a lot of questions.
>>James Ramsey: Or not.
>>Dan Barasch: Maybe you wanna--?
>>James Ramsey: So, we have this concept and
we welcome anyone here's support.
We think that it's a concept that, well, showcases
a new green technology.
I think it is an amenity for historically
under-served community.
And also, I think it hopefully pushes us in
a direction to maybe possibly rethink the
way that we deal with public spaces and specifically,
left-over infrastructure, by the use of applying
technology to actually begin to suit some
of those public needs.
So, anyway, I guess it would be probably a
good time to see if anyone here has any questions
or comments that they wanna rain down on us.
>>Dan Barasch: Let it rain.
>>James Ramsey: I don't know.
I don't work here.
>>MALE #2: I haven't been keeping up with
it, but I remember a few months ago the Department
of Transportation was talking about doing
a lot of construction on Delancey, the way
the bridge connects with Delancey.
Putting up a big wall, basically, perpendicular
to the bridge.
Does that conflict at all with what you're
doing?
Is that still happening?
>>James Ramsey: The proposal that he's referring
to has to do with the way that bikes come
down off of the bridge.
And I think it's safe here to say this.
I think it's a bonehead idea 'cause say you
are zooming down the bridge at like, Mach
Two, and then there's a concrete wall right
in front of you, right?
[laughter]
>>MALE #2: Yeah.
That's a popular opinion, I've heard.
>>James Ramsey: I mean, I think more to the
point, it does highlight that there is a pretty
hardcore circulation issue at that point.
I think that basically they built a corridor,
specifically based on cars and trucks.
And everything else is just an afterthought,
including human beings and bicycles.
And so, for anyone who's been hurtling down
that bridge, you're just unceremoniously dropped
at the end of the bridge into Delancey Street
traffic, which is, as we know, some of the
most dangerous in the city.
So, I think it's admirable that they are proposing
a solution to try and protect the bikers from
the car traffic.
I think that's a great step in the right direction.
We see this project as potentially posing
other solutions to that bike circulation issue
that who's repercussions we had ourselves
thought through all the way.
But we would hope that this addresses some
of those circulation issues directly.
>>MALE #2: Yeah, if you could be like, an
alternative to that, that'd be--.
>>James Ramsey: I mean, wouldn't that be cool?
Zoom down into there, reemerge.
You know, something like that.
>>FEMALE #1: Hey, how are you?
So, really cool technology.
Really awesome idea.
How much do you guys think it's gonna cost?
And where do you think the money's gonna come
from?
'Cause I'm assuming that the MTA does this.
That the MTA doesn’t have that much money
right now and probably wants to make a lot
of money on any purchase of what they own.
Is it--?
Are they looking to sell the city?
I mean, what kind of estimates do you guys
have about how much it's gonna cost?
Besides the technology, there's obviously
a big clean-up and then the safety issues
and then making it sanitary and all those
kinds of things after a hundred years.
>>James Ramsey: Right.
Plus getting into it and getting a wheelchair,
etcetera.
>>FEMALE #1: Right.
All of those types of things.
>>Dan Barasch: See, you pretty much nailed
why this is an amazing challenge, right?
[laughter]
And why we're spending all our time on this.
So, you're right.
So, just to address all of the different elements
there.
The MTA owns the space.
The MTA, you may have heard, is an agency
that is billions of dollars in debt.
And is looking to liquidate all its real estate
as much as it can.
This is obviously a location, interestingly,
that wasn't on the radar before we had started
talking about it.
And now, it's a much more interesting and
people have heard of the location over the
last few months.
We've been working really closely with the
MTA.
I'm understanding a little bit more about
what kinds of thresholds they would need in
order for us to submit the competing bid.
And there's a lot of people, both in the MTA
and outside the MTA, who think this is a wonderful
idea and are basically saying, "We give you
all of our support.
Essentially what you need to do is you need
to go and raise money."
And so, what we've done is we've set up a
501(c)3 non-profit organization, very similar
to the High Line, and again, taking a lot
of advice from the High Line founders on where
some of that money would come from.
So, we have a range of ways that we've benchmarked
how the cost would be.
It's all conjecture at this point because
there's so many questions we don't know around
what's gonna happen above ground.
We have a range of engineers and legal experts
and folks who are gonna help us come up with
a number that's actually a lot more realistic
and then will probably have to get thrown
away.
Interestingly, the High Line guys came up
with a number on how much it was gonna cost
them, that they were way off on and they realized
that only several years further into the process.
So,--.
>>FEMALE #1: They were under?
>>Dan Barasch: They were under significantly
actually, yeah.
But what the High Line guys--I think they're
really inspiring in a lot of ways--that what
they've proven to be is fund-raising juggernauts.
And what they've been able to do is to do
a mix of, if anyone has worked in or worked
with non-profits, it's a mix of a standard
non-profit fund-raising model of private donations,
corporate support, Google would be a wonderful
supporter, and foundation support.
And the High Line eventually also moved to
a membership-based model.
So, there's another fund-raising stream there,
too.
They've done all kinds of other interesting
things, too.
I mean, another interesting dimension of this
is that the neighborhood is extremely excited
about this as a business opportunity for existing
and new businesses.
The Lower East Side business district has
just actually officially endorsed us as our
representative on the city council.
And I think those two votes of support point
to the fact that the local business community
actually feels that this would be a tremendous
magnet and an important economic boon for
a neighborhood that often is where you go
to get drunk at night, but is actually not
necessarily a vibrant, deeply integrated business
community that others from other neighborhoods
and other countries and other cities come
to when they come to New York City.
So, the High Line has proven its tremendous
economic impact.
The numbers that are circling in my head is
that at this point, it's cost about 250 million
dollars to get the High Line to where it is
now.
But they've generated about two billion dollars
in value for the city and for the economy.
So, and that will only continue and grow over
time.
So, there's a larger story that we need to
be able to tell.
And a big part of what we're doing this year
is doing the research we need to be able to
land at some compelling numbers, not only
around cost, but also around the potentials
or benefit to the city.
Anyone want to step up to the mic?
>>MALE #3: Sure.
What kind of environmental remediation is
gonna need to be done on the site?
I mean, is it lead paint everywhere?
Is it more than that?
>>James Ramsey: Well, Dan actually, in addressing
the previous question, brought up the issue
of needing more information about what the
general costs of this overall project to construct
would actually be.
And I think you bring up a very valid and
interesting point, but until we actually get
a team of engineers, cleared by the MTA, to
go down into there and start exploring some
of the environmental conditions, it would
be difficult to say right off the bat.
I mean, look, dollars to donuts, there's probably
lead paint down there, right?
I mean, it's from 1903 for God's sake.
There's also drainage that needs to happen
and who knows what else.
I think what's working in our favor is the
fact that it was basically forgotten about
after 1943.
And there's just been nothing in there except
maybe the occasional mole person, right?
So, any sort of environmental issues that
might be at play with the space itself would
be ones that are created from the original
construction, like you say, from the lead
paint, for example.
[pause]
>>MALE #4: Hi.
I love the idea.
I saw this about six months ago and I thought
it was fantastic then.
I still think it's fantastic.
I had a question about the scale of it, though.
So, in these drawings, you modeled this all
out.
How large are the collectors?
How many of them do you need?
And where do you plan to put them above ground?
>>James Ramsey: Well, let's talk about two
things.
First of all, the space itself, I don't think
we got to this little factoid.
But the space itself is about 60 thousand
square feet, which is roughly equivalent in
size to the first leg of the High Line when
they built that.
It's also roughly equivalent in size to--this
is a terrible comparison--to two-thirds of
the size of Gramercy Park.
But I guess the case in point being, it is
a pretty large space.
Now, when you set up a technology like this--light
goes in, light goes out--you don't get to
save it.
You don't get to build it up or anything like
that.
Purely optical device.
So, in a vacuum, let's say you have a square
meter of collection.
You put in a hundred thousand lumens.
You have a distributer downstairs.
So, square meter in a vacuum, a hundred thousand
lumens comes out.
Of course, it's not gonna be a hundred percent
efficient.
You'll probably lose 20 percent of the light,
which is fine.
But, I guess, point being, you need to manage
how much light is going to be delivered to
certain areas as a design concept really and
based on what the light requirements of the
various plantings are actually gonna be.
So, without going into detail about the design
of the plantings and the landscape architecture,
it's difficult to say how much light you actually
need to deliver down there.
However, just my initial back of the napkin
projections in math indicate to me that for
one thing, I think these things want to live
on the elevated median that's currently in
the middle of Delancey Street.
It's on the north side of the site.
It will not fall into the shadows of the proposed
development that's going up to the south.
And it's an appropriate path for the lighting
to actually go filter through.
Now, as for the number of collectors that
we're talking about, I mean, it will depend
of course on how much light you need to deliver
down into the space.
But as far as arrays go, I would say probably
something like 30 or 40 of them or something
like that.
And of course, you can calibrate how much
light is getting in there by how much you
need, and therefore, what you need on the
topside, etc.
So,--.
>>MALE #4: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #2: Do you have a sense of, you mentioned
MTA was opening up this space for proposal.
>>James Ramsey: Yeah.
>>FEMALE #2: Who else is interested in it?
And how many other people--?
>>James Ramsey: It's just gonna be the world's
biggest Red Lobster.
[laughter]
And we're really gonna have to duke it out
with them.
>>Dan Barasch: Actually, that's really funny.
We had extreme fun of presenting this to a
high school yesterday morning.
And I think one of the kids said something
like, "Could this be a McDonald's?"
’Cause that would be really cool."
[laughter]
I think that's actually exactly what we're
trying not to do.
And so, they also demanded Wi-Fi, which I
thought was really funny.
>>James Ramsey: Like, all of them demanded
Wi-Fi.
Five bars.
>>Dan Barasch: Right, all the time.
And your iPhone will work down there.
But I think that we really don't know.
I think that the site is going to get more
and more interesting over the course of this
year if we have anything to say about it.
And I think that what we're trying to do is
to drive forward a sense that we are the folks
who are actually focused on the community.
And when other developers come to the table,
as they almost definitely will, who are interested
in doing interesting things or things that
have heavy retail component, that we actually
will be able to say actually we've spent the
time talking to the community about what it
wants to do and this isn't simply a conversation
around short-term gain for MTA, but there
are other factors at play and there's a community
here and there's people who actually need
some green space.
So, I think that's where we're coming from.
>>James Ramsey: You know it's funny that the
irony here is that, just broadly speaking,
the reason that you don't find so much green
space in any New York neighborhood is because
there exists this very focused market-driven
mentality, well, throughout the city.
And so, setting aside a piece of land for
just general public use is, it's a very rare
thing in this town.
And so, here we are.
And we discover a giant space that no one
even knew about, all these square feet.
And now all of a sudden, it's like, OK.
So, we've gotta look at this competitive development
schemes to generate money from this thing.
I think that's, of course, it's fair to say
it's not our space.
It's the MTA's space.
We would very much like to build them an economic
model that actually shows that this thing
can actually turn a profit as well.
>>Dan Barasch: Actually, I mean, on that point,
the High Line is a recent example of something
that, in our lifetime, actually for most of
us who have been in New York throughout the
entire process, a group of individuals who
are just from the community decided to say,
"We actually want to fight to turn this, to
A, not tear it down and B, turn it into an
actual, public space that's free, that's green,
that's beautiful."
And actually, in New York City's history,
most of the parks and green spaces in the
city happened that way, either through community
activism or through the creation of a private-led
park.
So, even looking at things like the saving
of Grand Central was something where a bunch
of pissed off people said, "We really want
this to be saved," and not turned into something
that isn't stunning, beautiful, and for the
public.
So, I think the examples of that go all the
way through New York City's history.
And the interesting thing is obviously just
that the Park's Department just announced
a budget cut yesterday.
So, it's an increasing age of public austerity
and there just isn't a sense that the government
is going to be able to have the resources
to step in and have a vision for a green space.
And so, I think what's exciting about the
High Line and hopefully what we're doing,
is that a private-driven and community-led
approach to building a park is potentially
the wave of the future.
And is actually the way that parks will get
built and space will be saved for the public.
>>MALE #5: What are you planning to do [inaudible]?
[inaudible]?
>>James Ramsey: Well, I mean, when the sun
goes down these devices no longer produce
any light.
So, is the solution to just close it at dark,
or is the solution to actually supplement
the light?
I think that you will want to create a hybridized
system one way or another so you have the
option, like some very high-powered LED's
or something built in-line to simulate maximum
capacity of the sun when it's not out there.
Like, on a really dark day, like the one we
had a couple days ago, I mean, it will be
fairly dark down here and you don't get the
other ambient light that filters through the
clouds in the sky, etc., like you do in an
above-ground space.
So, I think it would be important to supplement--.
At least have the ability to supplement that
light.
>>MALE #5: You could simulate the night sky.
>>James Ramsey: Or you could just--.
Ooh.
Actually, if you just point this thing at
the sun at sunset, you will get a sunset.
So, you'll get an orange and purple space,
which I think is kinda cool.
>>Dan Barasch: The MTA made this weird promotional
video for the site.
And in it, the MTA spokesman made a joke about
how it could become a nightclub, which was
so weird coming from a public official.
[laughter]
But one of the really fun things that we saw
in the location on our tour was this abandoned
control tower, this weird little space, totally
graffiti-full and you could tell people slept
in there over the years, and immediately we
were like, "This would be an incredible say,
tree house, for kids.
Or, just this really amazing space that could
be transformed into something really fun."
>>James Ramsey: Isn't it fun we're talking
about tree houses and the MTA is talking about
a DJ booth?
[laughter]
>>Dan Barasch: Clearly, they want the party
to go on all night.
But so, the possibility of what else could
happen down there.
I mean, again, I think one of the things that
we need to be totally serious about is that
we do need a real business model.
And there's a lot of different ways of thinking
about how we use the space during the day
as well as the way we think about it during
the night.
And the High Line has interestingly first
saved the space, and then built an amazing
park, and they're now evolving a lot of their
approach to ways that they can stay in business
as a park.
The High Line needs to continue to raise money
in order to sustain itself as a private park.
So, this will be hopefully the same sort of
model in which we'll need to, over time, continue
to sustain ourselves.
So, what is that business model?
Maybe there are the opportunities to do nice
things in there at night.
>>James Ramsey: I think it is noteworthy that
you do control the entrances and the exits
to the space because it's underground.
And so, I think that very much opens the door
to what I think Dan is leading into about
being able to have alternate uses for daytime,
nighttime, other times, etcetera.
>>Dan Barasch: New York's hottest club.
[laughter]
>>James Ramsey: Right.
>>MALE #6: So, there's a really large elderly
community in the area with a lot of political
influence.
Looking at this, this would be the perfect
place for them to be outside but not really
outside.
Have you [inaudible]?
>>James Ramsey: We've reached out to a lot
of the housing in the neighborhood, not specifically
to the elderly, but I think you make a really
interesting point in that because it's underground,
well, it never rains down there.
It never snows down there.
And the temperature is a very even 60-ish.
And so, I think actually that's a really good
idea.
I actually am not familiar with any sort of
organizations, specifically, in that neighborhood
that we could reach out to wholesale, but
it's a good idea.
>>Dan Barasch: Well, we've also heard a lot
about how young people would actually use
the space.
I mean, there's actually a lot of families.
I mean, one of the great things about the
Lower East Side, and especially this whole
corridor and this part of the Lower East Side,
is that it's really, really diverse.
A lot of it is populated by people who are
on affordable or subsidized housing.
And it's ethnically really diverse.
And it has this really vibrant community that
takes care of itself because frankly, I think
a lot of it is because people have lived there
for generations and the business community
is very Mom and Pop and it has this community
feel.
And yet, there's a sense that young people
don't really have a lot of green space.
There's nowhere to go with kids.
I mean, as a parent, where do you go with
your kids when it's not nice out on the weekends?
And so, we've heard a lot of comments on how
people would use the space.
And it's interesting 'cause this is actually
the first time, I think, that someone has
suggested to us that old people would use
the space.
I think it's exciting to think about that,
too.
>>FEMALE #3: What are they thinking about
with the High Line was the architecture company
[inaudible].
Are you guys thinking about having something
like that, or are you pretty much gonna go
with what you have here?
>>James Ramsey: That's a good question.
Well, as an architect, I would feel a little
bit weird about it, I guess.
>>FEMALE #3: Well, you build the technology,
so I can see having a [inaudible].
>>James Ramsey: I mean, I think it would be
a great idea to open up many elements of this
to competition.
We haven't fleshed out a program.
We haven't really specified what goes on in
there.
We're deliberately leaving these things blank.
We haven't specified what these things above
ground actually look like.
We haven't specified what the entries look
like.
And so, I mean, I think all of those things
are open and probably would be benefited by
some sort of competition.
What we're proposing is actually in and of
itself already so specific that it would be
hard for me to envision the, I guess, within
this defined set of design constraints, all
this diversity of ideas that the High Line
generated.
Like, you will recall, there was one that
turned the entire thing into a pool.
There's one that turned the entire thing into
a jail.
I think that we could, well, we could turn
this whole thing into a pool, certainly, or
an ice rink, or a jail.
Actually, it would make a really good jail.
>>Dan Barasch: A really fun jail.
[laughter]
>>James Ramsey: But in and of--.
The design is actually, again, the concept
itself is so specific already.
It makes it a little bit challenging to do
that.
>>Dan Barasch: But actually just on that point,
I mean, I think there's three classes at Columbia
University that are like, teaching or they
are using this as architecture studios.
And we get a lot of people reaching out to
us from NYU, from a lot of other universities,
literally around the world.
So, I think there already have been or are
going to be a lot of really amazing ideas
that come out of this.
And I think it'll be fun to bring people in
to the idea over the next year.
>>MALE #7: So, I happen to live on Pitt Street,
right there.
>>James Ramsey: Cool.
>>MALE #7: So, my question.
I have two.
One is, I'm interested in the development
on the south side of Delancey, what you've
heard about that.
>>James Ramsey: SPURA.
Yeah?
>>MALE #7: So, that's part one.
Two, you have the economic diversity of the
neighborhood, do you have any thoughts about
this being successful impact on things like
real estate?
>>James Ramsey: The questions are actually
interrelated.
Are you on Clinton between Delancey and--?
>>MALE #7: Between Staten Road.
>>James Ramsey: If you go one block south,
there is a bar called Second Floor on Clinton
and they are now serving a cocktail called
"The Low Line."
[laughter]
So, if you have the chance, go check it out.
>>Dan Barasch: It's delicious.
It's a modified Negroni.
>>James Ramsey: Yeah, it's a Negroni with
rye.
It's really good.
Anyway, so first of all, the site immediately
to the south was knocked down in the Robert
Moses era.
It looked a lot like the neighborhood to the
north and it was just unceremoniously bulldozed
to make way for, I don't know, either for
progress or to get rid of dirtiness.
It's unclear which of the two it was.
But they actually never built back what they
had originally planned for that neighborhood
right there.
And because this neighborhood happens really
at the nexus point of so many different ethnicities
and neighborhoods, I mean, you've got the
Orthodox Jewish community, you've got the
Chinese, you've got the Dominicans, you've
got the Puerto Ricans, you've got the hipsters,
all meeting at this one little point, it's
been a hotly contested neighborhood for something
like 40 years.
And as a result, they have not reached a consensus
to build something there until very recently
anyway.
So, within the last what?
Year, year and a half, something like that,
they finally reached a consensus for what
to do with it.
And this is the part that relates directly
to what you're talking about demographically.
The consensus that they reached is they're
gonna build a million and a half square feet
distributed across all of these sites.
And almost half of that square footage is
going to be devoted specifically to affordable
housing.
So, I think we have a built-in system for
that development itself that actually very
strongly preserves the demographic mix of
the neighborhood.
>>Dan Barasch: Cool.
Do we have time for a few more questions?
>>James Ramsey: Don't you guys have to work
or something?
Seriously.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: I think we have room for
another half hour, but--.
>>Dan Barasch: I guess maybe we'll take a
few more questions, if that's OK.
>>MALE #8: I just have one quick question.
I know that you guys mentioned possibly placing
the light devices on the shoulder or the median.
Is there any plans to do more on the surface?
That's such a weird area.
>>James Ramsey: It is a weird area, yes.
>>MALE #8: I live there and I think it's like
this bizarre zone.
>>James Ramsey: Well, it's like this plastic
bags like tumbleweeds, just going down the
street.
As part of the development that I just alluded
to, called SPURA, Seward Park Urban Renewal
Area, which is all through that south site
with all those parking lots that you see right
there, there is also going to be a rethinking
of a master plan for that whole south side.
And possibly for a portion of Delancey Street
itself.
We just don't know that information yet 'cause
they're not done designing it.
>>MALE #8: Independent of this initiative.
>>James Ramsey: That's right.
But of course, they're inextricably linked.
We're tied very much to what they decide to
do.
>>FEMALE #4: [inaudible] toward the water
or--?
>>James Ramsey: Or like, on the bridge or
something.
You know, that's the thing.
And you're hitting the nail on the head.
But just in researching this, I mean, you
can obviously concentrate light down and send
it through just an empty shaft and send it
wherever you need it to go.
It will require some pretty hardcore precision
to do that.
So, you can, I think, feasibly do that for
a small amount of distance.
But if you go into a fiber optic cable, there
is, of course, attenuation.
And intercontinental cables under the sea
that transmit data or whatever, they have
these boosters that help nudge things along.
Obviously, we can't do that with the sun,
or else we're just paying for electricity.
We have an attenuation that really puts our
limit on the fiber cables themselves at about,
I don't know, like 20, 30, 40 meters, something
like that.
>>MALE #9: [inaudible]
>>James Ramsey: So, maybe we just float collectors
in the East River.
Pipe it over and then who cares about all
the loss?
I think that's a pretty cool idea.
>>MALE #9: [inaudible ]
>>James Ramsey: Are you happy with your job
right now?
[laughter]
That's awesome.
>>Dan Barasch: So, do we have time for one
more?
Cool.
Last one.
>>MALE #10: Not to get a little personal,
but it seems like it requires a lot of time
and devotion and you're visiting with us now,
you have some sort of breaking point in the
future--
>>James Ramsey: Breaking point.
>>MALE #10: not necessarily asking what's
in it for you, but hypothetically.
>>James Ramsey: Right.
Well, it's like being Batman.
We have our day jobs of course.
And they're what enable us to pay New York
rents.
We are largely doing this as a project in
our free time and have been doing so for the
past couple of years.
But obviously recently it's been demanding
increasing amounts of time.
So, this is actually neck in neck with us
actually building and fleshing out an organization
with more people.
And actually, Dan can actually speak to this
better than I can, but it is something that
we're able to actually distribute the workload
amongst people as well.
Did I say that right?
>>Dan Barasch: Yeah.
You did.
>>James Ramsey: Just curious.
Anyone else?
Last chance.
All right.
Well, look.
Thank you, everyone.
I hope you all find this project as exciting
as we obviously do.
And if you're really excited about it, please
just talk to us.
Maybe you can help us make this thing happen.
All right?
Yeah, OK.
Thank you.
>>Dan Barasch: As just one last point, so
we, as I mentioned, we're doing the kick starter
in just a couple weeks.
So, if you're interested in getting involved,
that's one way.
And then obviously, you can follow us on Facebook
and Twitter.
Check out our site.
We have a newsletter just to keep people inside
the loop on all of our little political developments
and what we're up to.
So, we'd love to hear from you and just stay
in touch.
Anyway.
Thanks again for your time.
[applause]